Vamos a continuar en el estudio con más
información y para ello me acompaña
Daniela Blandón Daniela Un saludo para
usted Hola Muy buenos días Ángela
Daniela al cumplirse veinte años de la
invasión aira Cuál ha sido el costo
calculado pues Ángela mire esta invasión
dejó este país es devastado no solamente
física sino económicamente de acuerdo
con un informe del Brown University de
Estados Unidos Los costos totales para
Washington de Las Guerras en Irak y
Siria que se espera super en el medio
millón de Vidas perdidas han sido de 1,8
billones de dólares millones de millones
para hacer una comparación esta cantidad
es ocho veces el producto interno bruto
de un año en un país de tamaño medio
como Perú pero si se le suman los costos
de manutención de los veteranos de
guerra hasta el 2050 esa cifras según
esta universidad se incrementaría los
2,9 billones de dólares hay un dato
adicional Es que la administración de
Joe biden está pidiendo al congreso
cuarenta y dos mil millones de dólares
para el pentágono en el año
presupuestario
2024 Esta es la solicitud más grande
desde el pico de esas guerras de Irak y
Afganistán A mediados de la década del
2000 cuando las cientos de miles de
tropas desplegadas dispararon el gasto
de guerra en el extranjero de Estados
Unidos Daniela Cómo está la economía del
país teniendo en cuenta todos estos
datos pues 20 años después la gente
todavía no se recupera de la guerra
evidentemente su población pasó de 26
millones a 43 millones en este tiempo la
invasión sumada a la rampante corrupción
de la clase gobernante instaurada
durante la ocupación ha estancado a la
nación en una espiral de crisis a pesar
de ser uno de los países más ricos en
petróleo del planeta según transparencia
internacional Irak ocupa el puesto 157
entre 180 países en el índice de
corrupción ahora veamos la economía está
estancada y vamos a dar un ejemplo eso
se nota en el desempleo que en 2022 un
año antes de la invasión como vemos era
del 8,9%, hoy 20 años después después de
haber subido están 16,5% según el Banco
Mundial esto es casi el doble de lo que
estaba en ese momento también hay una
inflación vertiginosa alimentada por
supuesto también por la pandemia y la
guerra en Ucrania en los últimos años
como lo dicen algunos de sus residentes
sigue siendo el mismo y nada ha cambiado
los ciudadanos esperaban algo mejor pero
no hay cambios
los cambios en el tipo de cambio del
dólar han afectado al mercado y a la
gente porque sus ingresos se han vuelto
limitados anteriormente el salario
duraba un mes pero ahora solo cubre dos
semanas 14 o 15 días y ya no está
los estadounidenses vinieron y dijeron
les daremos todo lo que necesiten
raciones de alimentos completas caminos
pavimentados sistemas de alcantarillado
y electricidad nada de eso sucedió
simplemente vinieron destruyeron el país
robaron la riqueza y la gente de Irak y
luego se fueron esta situación Ángela Es
particularmente difícil cuando los
musulmanes se preparan para el mes
sagrado del ramadán que inicia el
próximo miércoles las compras previas
son una atención para algunos iraquíes
debido a una crisis monetaria que vive
el país A eso se le suman los graves
problemas de suministro de Electricidad
pues depende mucho de las importaciones
de gas de su vecino Irán Y es que los
iraquíes no entienden como el segundo
mayor productor de la OPEP que genera
unos 8 mil millones de dólares al mes en
exportaciones de petróleo es incapaz de
proveer servicios básicos a la población
bueno para allá iba ha sido una potencia
petrolera que ha pasado en 20 años pues
este país como muchos de sus vecinos ha
tenido el petróleo como una de sus
principales fuentes de ingresos no en
vano Irak es miembro fundador de la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo tiene un Boss y voto Dentro de
este grupo que equipara gran parte de la
oferta mundial de crudo en 2002 vamos a
verlo también antes de la invasión su
producción era de 2,1 millones de
barriles por día en ese momento era el
décimo primer mayor productor mundial de
petróleo en todos estos 20 años ha ido
ascendiendo ha ido escalando y ya
produce 4,1 millones de barriles por día
esto lo convierte en el quinto mayor
productor de petróleo del mundo según el
Instituto internacional de investigación
para la paz estocolmo estas
exportaciones de petróleo representaron
aproximadamente el 95% de los ingresos
federales en 2020 y los sucesivos
gobiernos pues han hecho poco para sacar
a la nación de esta fuerte y muy
peligrosa dependencia de y para pues
diversificar la economía Qué es lo que
hace la dependencia del petróleo por
ejemplo lo vemos en 2020 cuando los
precios mundiales se desplomaron como
consecuencia de la pandemia y el
gobierno no pudo financiar los servicios
básicos y hasta dejó de pagar salarios y
pensiones del sector público seis de
cada diez empleados en Irak son del
sector público en ese momento la deuda
pública alcanzó el 84% del pib y el pib
en sí mismo llegó a caer un 16% según
este mismo instituto Aunque es una
situación generalizada en todo el mundo
de todas maneras en Irak si se vio pues
más afectado porque depende de su
economía casi en un 100% del petróleo
entonces sigue siendo inexplicable ahora
este país también Daniela seguía o solía
ser un destino turístico por excelencia
claro Yo es que en este momento pues si
aún no le mencionan Irak para ir de
vacaciones puede que mucha gente lo
piense porque cree que es un país que ha
estado en guerra por tantos años y que
no vale la pena ir a esta nación Y es
que con la invasión de Estados Unidos la
población irá Aquí también perdió un
patrimonio cultural inmenso vamos a ver
después de la toma de Bagdad saqueadores
entraron a los museos de la capital
también lo hicieron a las bibliotecas a
los sitios arqueológicos destruyeron y
robaron bienes culturales muchos de
ellos que se remontan a la historia de
la Mesopotamia antigua Pues habían
quedado sin protección del ejército
estadounidense adicionalmente con los
años de ocupación de las tropas también
se presentaron múltiples irregularidades
en los inventarios y de antigüedades y
muchos bienes llegaron inclusive a
desaparecer hoy el país está intentando
a esos turistas para que vuelvan a los
lugares históricos como la ciudad
bíblica de Babilonia que supuestamente
albergó los jardines colgantes Allí se
destaca el turismo arqueológico y
también el turismo religioso ya que es
un país conocido como la cuna de la
civilización y donde surgieron claves
para el desarrollo de la humanidad por
ejemplo la escritura las leyes
codificadas la rueda o Inclusive la
agricultura todo esto se vino abajo
Ángela con la invasión
pues Daniela creo que así llegamos a un
completo resumen de lo que es la
situación económica por estos días en
Irak y hay que decirlo no un país que
definitivamente no ha podido recuperarse
Pese a que la invasión determinó ya hace
muchos años y que no ve la luz de
ninguna manera claro no ve la luz y de
todas maneras Ángela para cualquier país
que dependa tanto de una materia prima
con el como el petróleo es muy difícil
esa dependencia Ya que en momentos como
en la guerra en Ucrania cuando el barril
llegó a ubicarse en 140 dólares pues es
muy bueno para para para las arcas del
estado y pueden pagar los salarios de
sus empleados que como lo decíamos Son
seis de cada 10 empleados de todo el
país sin embargo cuando hay vacas flacas
como se conoce y cuando el petróleo
llega a los 30 dólares o cuando
inclusive hubo en el peor momento de la
pandemia llegó a cotizarse en negativo
pues en ese momento es cuando ya
el estado se queda sin dinero y no puede
suministrarle a la gente pues sus
servicios básicos por lo menos bueno Y
eso lo vemos también si uno Lee
cualquier artículo que haya en prensa lo
que se dice es que la democracia no está
bien instaurada hay mucha debilidad
institucional así que bueno Esto es una
espiral de inestabilidad para el país Yo
le agradezco Daniela y nos vemos más
adelante nos vemos más adelante y
también quería hacer Ultra una última
cuñada y es he escuchado de muchas
personas que irá que es un país hermoso
que es un país que tiene unos paisajes
muy que vale la pena visitar pero
lastimosamente Pues por este tema de la
guerra ha quedado como en el olvido por
los turistas muy lamentable Gracias
Daniela Bueno nos vemos en la próxima